and of course the misinformation that
was flowing during covet has not slowed
down in fact it has gotten worse
according to a new
report from m booth health
a study called the pharma brandemic
more than one thousand demographically
diverse adults across the united states
were polled
and here's what they found the
overwhelming majority of respondents 88
percent have encountered health care
misinformation and nearly three quarters
73 percent are anxious about it
more than one in three believe they come
across false health information almost
every day
so health misinformation
in case you haven't noticed
is growing out of control
these these alleged crackdowns by social
media outlets and youtube like oh we're
not going to let all this you know
misinformation out there we're finally
taking down the massive anti-vaxx
facebook page that should have been
taken down years ago
that by the way that group the
children's health defense i think they
made what six million dollars last year
i think is what i had read um they make
a lot of money whether it's 6 million or
not
they do make a lot of money
and
they were removed because facebook
finally said we think this is
misinformation we've got polio in new
york
that's what medical misinformation does
a million people dead from covet in this
country
that's what medical misinformation
does
but that's not even the striking part of
this study from in booth health
here's the striking part to me
separately
we also this from the daily beast by the
way separately we also surveyed 101
full-time health care providers
almost all 99
of them
said they have patients share
misinformation every week and 90 of
medical professionals are anxious about
this
nearly half 48 percent say they now have
less confidence that patients will
comply with their recommendations
perhaps unsurprisingly the same
percentage of patients 48 percent say
they are now more comfortable
challenging their doctor
so all of this misinformation
and there's another part to it other
than just misinformation i'll get to
that in a moment but all of this
misinformation what it's doing right now
according to doctors and health care
workers is you've got people walking
into the doctor's office the doctor says
okay look you have this problem we're
going to do x y and z we're going to get
you fixed up hopefully and we're going
to make you better
and the patient says now hold on there
jack
i may not have gone to medical school
but i saw on facebook right from this uh
this this very important group they've
got like 10 million followers
they say you're wrong
they say give me the horse medicine
that's what i want maybe i should have
gone to the vet instead
and the doctors like they can't do
anything about it they can sit there and
say well as somebody that went to
medical school and has been practicing
medicine for a couple decades you're
wrong please do what i'm saying
and then the patient leaves and half the
doctors are like yeah that person's not
going to listen to me
doctors are getting burned out from this
the report also states
because you know why the burnout happens
because when that patient that doesn't
want to take the doctor's advice because
they know better because they read it on
facebook
they don't listen to the doctor they get
worse they come back
and no matter how many i told you so as
the doctor gives the patient still
insists
no
i'm still right i may be on my deathbed
because i didn't listen to you but darn
it i'm still right
until of course their final moments as
we saw plenty of times during the
pandemic
people on their death bed saying i wish
i'd gotten the shot
i wish i had taken this seriously
i wish i hadn't followed the
misinformation
that's what we're seeing in this country
and as i mentioned there's another part
of it too
it's not just the misinformation
it's the overwhelming amount of
information
and that overwhelming amount of
information i'm talking about is coming
from the drug drug companies themselves
another thing that's happening that's
also
frustrating doctors to no end
is the fact that we have direct to
consumer advertising of prescription
drugs here in the united states
and what's been happening for 20 years
now
is that patients go into the doctor's
office
not waiting for the doctor to tell them
what they need but they go in and act
like they're ordering at a deli
they say hey doc yeah i've got these
problems but i saw this commercial on tv
i want that drug i want that thing
the people in the commercial looked all
happy they're dancing i want to dance
give me the drug and if you think i'm
making that up
go and look through all the studies from
the last 20 years that have shown that
people are now walking into the doctor's
office demanding give me this thing i
saw on tv
which is why we're one of only two
countries on the planet new zealand
being the other one that even allows
that to happen in the first place the
direct to consumer advertising that's
where we're at today
we're inundated with news from big
pharma
saying hey you need this drug all these
people in the commercial taking it they
look happy they're fun you know they're
living their lives don't you want to
live your life
and then on the other side you have
people saying oh no you don't need any
of this
what you need is to go out there and eat
a couple of handfuls of dirt
and that'll make it all better
don't don't trust big pharma and so we
are stuck in this in between
i have seen
again through my work for almost 20
years with with various law firms i've
seen the documents from big pharma these
folks are scumbags up and down no
question about it
they will lie to your face about a drug
that is going to kill you and tell you
it's the only thing you ever need to
take and you're going to be great
it is difficult to trust these
individuals at the same time they do
still produce life-saving medication
so it's easy to see how you get to that
misinformation
there is a lot of distrust there and
there should be
because again a lot of the people
including some of the prominent
anti-vaxxers they fought these companies
in court
but it skewed them to the point where
they now believe you can't trust
anything
the truth is somewhere in between
and unfortunately for doctors
the public doesn't know what to do they
don't know who to trust
we're just kind of left in the middle
big pharma is greedy big pharma rips us
off
big pharma tries to sell us drugs we
don't need
but they also make things we do need
like vaccines
and life-saving medications
that we just wish we could afford to
take
but then all of that greed
all of those horrible documents
feeds into the you can't trust big
pharma they're only out to kill you
misinformation
it's a vicious cycle
and it is almost entirely
a uniquely american cycle
we have to take another quick break i am
fair and cousins find me on twitter
instagram and facebook at
and cousins i'm in for david pakman this
is the david pakman show and we'll be
right back